بدلاً من بولي المعتاد الذي يريد
تكسيرًا ، يسأل مالكو الببغاوات عما إذا كانت
بولي تريد محادثة فيديو ،
هل تريد التحدث معها ،
حسنًا ، يكفي أن تجعل بوب
ببغاء وحيد رأسه
بإثارة وورقة بعنوان طيور على شكل
ريش فيديو  جمع الباحثون معًا
وصفوا تعليم 18 ببغاءًا أليفًا لقرع
الجرس
[موسيقى]
عندما قرعوا الجرس ، تم
تزويدهم بجهاز لوحي
ترغب في الاتصال به
ومنحهم خيارًا من الببغاوات لإجراء
محادثة فيديو تريد الاتصال بها  روزي على مدى
ثلاثة أشهر ،
يا سامي حسنًا ، لقد قدمت الببغاوات 147
طلبًا لإجراء مكالمات فيديو ، وظيفة جيدة ، حيث تم
استدعاء جورجي كثيرًا مع
طيور VIP ، بعض الطيور الباردة التي تم استدعاء بعض الطيور
أقل من أولئك الذين تم الاتصال بهم
أكثر كانوا هم أيضًا  قام
الباحثون بأكبر عدد من المكالمات التي يمكن للباحثين أن يخبروا بها
أن الطيور كانت منخرطة حقًا لأنهم
جلسوا معًا حاولوا لمس
بعضهم البعض وقاموا بتقليد بعضهم البعض وحتى
نوعًا ما غنوا بشكل
جيد ، لذا ربما لم تكن هناك لحظات فيلم Love Struck
فهي جميلة
ولكن إذا كنت تبحث عن الببغاوات
هناك إثارة أكبر من هذا
في بعض الأحيان قد يتصل بنا طائر عن طريق الخطأ ،
لذا في وقت ما كنت في اجتماع أو أعطي
فصلًا دراسيًا أو في المنزل وكنت أتلقى
مكالمة هاتفية من طائر تخيل رؤيته على
معرف المتصل الخاص بك Sammy the parrot
[موسيقى]
سي إن إن نيويورك
ما رأيك كوركي